- Oh, dude, that's an
We're stopping here, bro.
- All right.
Look at that body style.
Really guessing it's a 69.
Hello?
Yes?
How are you, sir?
- I'm good.
- Good, good.
My name is Danny.
- Ronald.
It is a pleasure
to meet you, sir.
- OK, same here.
- You have great taste.
And that Grand Prix over there
got my undivided attention.
All right.
And I was wondering
if I could chat with you
for a moment about that car.
- You sure can.
Is it a '69?
No, '71.
Darn it, man.
I was-- I was off, man.
Debuting in 1962, the Grand
Prix was Pontiac's luxury
performance car, and
like many other Pontiacs,
its history lies
mostly in motor sports.
Not only in its
name, the Grand Prix
was a favorite among
professional NASCAR drivers.
But that almost wasn't the case.
After a terrible accident during
a Le Mans race in 1955, General
Motors-- who owned Pontiac--
agreed to an industry-wide
ban on auto racing.
But knowing that racing
was the key to success,
Pontiac fought to
keep its presence.
The Grand Prix, along
with other Pontiac cars,
went on to become a leading
player in the racing world.
What's the story on
this car, Ronald?
Are you the original owner?
Oh, that is a rarity.
What's under the hood, sir?
It's the 400?
Very nice.
It's bone stock.
Ronald, this is a cool ride.
Is this a car that
you would sell?
It is?
So Mike and I were on a hunt for
a flip to just kind of butter
up Kevin a little bit,
in case he freaks out
over the CHIPS bike for Steve.
So we found this way
cool looking Grand Prix.
I just don't know
if this guy is going
to want too much money for it.
What would you want for this?
It's all original.
I don't-- I don't even know--
I don't even know
what this car's worth.
You don't see them.
What did they offer you?
What'd you tell him?
OK.
And he never showed up.
Yes, sir.
You have loved this
car for a long time,
and the last thing
you want is somebody
who's going to treat it wrong.
And that's not us.
A car like this, we would
treat with so much respect.
I won't even let Mike touch it.
Ronald, you are
a gentlemen, sir.
Thank you.
You know, seven grand is
not that bad of a price
for a '71 Grand Prix.
It's not in that
good of a shape,
and I don't know how
hard the parts are
going to be to find for this.
So I'm going to do
a little research.
And if it turns out like
it could be a winner,
I know where it's at.
Now, that right there,
my man, that right there?
That might be us.
I think it is, man.
[music playing]